el último delirio cinematográfico de
West Anderson y el más reciente drama
del italiano marco velozio entraron en
la competencia de cannes
[Música]
el excéntrico wes Anderson regresó a la
alfombra roja de cannes con la última
locura de su autoría asteroide City es
una fábula de extraterrestres y niños
científicos en un desierto de colores
chillones
lleva su sello inconfundible una
estética precisa movimientos laterales
de cámara humor ácido y una buena dosis
de situaciones absurdas las películas de
West Anderson están plagadas de
estrellas de alto calibre y así es
asteroide City Tom hanks Scarlett
Johansson
eran tantos que llegaron en un autobús
al estreno de la película en el Palacio
de los festivales
[Música]
un drama histórico sobre el secuestro de
un niño judío por el Vaticano en el
siglo 19 repito El secuestro narra la
verdadera historia de Edgardo un niño
judío de 6 años arrancado a su familia
por la iglesia luego de que una de las
sirvientas de la casa lo bautizara en
secreto cuando era un bebé intenta ganar
la palma de oro con este drama sobre la
crueldad del Vaticano un caso que tomó
dimensiones políticas y que llevó a la
comunidad judía internacional a desafiar
a la iglesia